Adventure has a name! Or, actually, it has
eight. From the man himself to a literal baby,
these are the actors who have played the
legendary archaeologist Indiana Jones.
Harrison Ford first appeared as Indiana
Jones in 1981's Raiders of the Lost Ark,
instantly cementing the character's reputation as
a cinematic legend. After Raiders, Ford appeared
in four more Jones adventures: Temple of Doom,
The Last Crusade, Kingdom of the Crystal Skull,
and Dial of Destiny. Ford is more or less
synonymous with Indy, which is all the more
remarkable considering George Lucas and Steven
Spielberg initially cast Tom Selleck for the part.
"Look, I did what I did, I don't
expect you to be happy about it.
Thought maybe it could do us both some good."
Selleck was too busy racing around
Hawaii in a red Ferrari on Magnum P.I.,
however, and Ford landed the role instead.
Of course, Indiana Jones is just one of the
iconic characters Harrison Ford has played in
his illustrious career. Before Raiders, he had
portrayed another of George Lucas' swaggering
hot-shot rogues: Han Solo in Star Wars. He also
starred as Rick Deckard in the dystopian sci-fi
classic Blade Runner, played Dr. Richard Kimble
in The Fugitive, kicked butt as US President James
Marshall in Air Force One… the list is nearly
endless, in fact, and in the years since Raiders,
Ford has become one of Hollywood's most iconic
actors. Not too shabby for an ex-carpenter.
River Phoenix plays a young Indiana Jones in the
opening sequence of The Last Crusade. In the third
installment of the franchise, boy scout Indy takes
on a gang of grave robbers bent on stealing a
golden crucifix for a mysterious benefactor.
Racing through the rugged Utah landscape,
Indy does his best to thwart the thieves
— but his efforts prove unsuccessful.
"You lost today, kid. But that
doesn't mean you have to like it."
While they don't share any
scenes in The Last Crusade,
this wasn't the first time Phoenix
had crossed paths with Harrison Ford;
he had previously played Ford's
son in 1986's The Mosquito Coast.
By the time Phoenix took on
the role of Indiana Jones,
he was already one of Hollywood's most
promising young stars. He starred in the
1986 coming-of-age classic Stand
By Me, and, at just 17 years old,
delivered an Oscar-nominated performance in
Running On Empty. Tragically, Phoenix died in
1993 at age 23 from a drug overdose. At the time
of Phoenix's death, Ford told the New York Times:
"He played my son once, and I
came to love him like a son,
and was proud to watch him grow into a man
of such talent and integrity and compassion."
Veteran stage actor George Hall played
the elderly Indiana Jones in The Young
Indiana Jones Chronicles. Episodes of The Young
Indiana Jones Chronicles are framed by old Indy's
memories and he serves as narrator for the show's
adventures — although this older Indy was edited
out of the series when George Lucas re-cut
it as The Adventures of Young Indiana Jones.
Indiana Jones came late in Hall's decades-long
acting career. He trained at the Neighborhood
Playhouse School and worked in vaudeville
before hitting the Broadway stage in the
1940s. Hall died in 2002 at the age of 85, having
performed on stage just weeks before his death.
Sean Patrick Flanery played a young Indy in the
'90s series The Young Indiana Jones Chronicles,
as well as several TV movies. George Lucas
hatched the idea for a prequel series as
a way to answer fans' questions about
the character. He cast Flanery as Indy
because he embodied the enthusiastic
innocence that Lucas was looking for.
"Oh, I've got a bad feeling about this."
And while Lucas intended The Young Indiana Jones
Chronicles to educate as much as entertain,
there's still plenty of action
and adventure to be had. Flanery,
a former autocross racer and
triathlete, threw himself into the
physically demanding role of young Indy,
even performing most of his own stunts.
The role of Indiana Jones kicked off Flanery's
Hollywood career, which quickly moved into
lead-role status for 1995's fantasy drama Powder.
He made a name for himself as a gritty action
star, and is today best known for his part in
The Boondock Saints. As for returning as Indiana
Jones? Well, Flanery certainly wouldn't turn down
the opportunity. As he told PopCulture in 2021:
"Man, I can probably count on one
hand the amount of people that
wouldn't want to do something
that George Lucas originated."
Corey Carrier played an even younger Indiana
Jones in The Young Indiana Jones Chronicles,
depicting Indy as a globe-trotting nine-year-old.
Under the supervision of his parents, Henry Jones,
Sr. and Anna Jones, Carrier's version
of young Indy takes in the wonders of
the world — and gets into a little trouble
along the way. Even young Indy didn't want
to be locked away in the classroom for too
long, and his formative experiences offer
some welcome context for the adult version
of Indiana Jones we've all grown to love.
Carrier maintained an active acting career in
the '90s, including roles as a young Richard
Nixon in director Oliver Stone's 1995 film Nixon
and Pinocchio's mischievous chum Lampwick in The
Adventures of Pinocchio. Since then, Carrier
has been living his life mostly off-screen.
Yes, we're including the baby, too. Credited
for just a single episode, Neil Boulane played
an infant version of Indiana Jones in The
Indiana Jones Chronicles. Little Henry
grows up after several scenes, ready to take on
more mature, childhood adventures. Albeit brief,
Boulane's performance gives some important
context to a famous part of Indiana Jones lore.
"You know how it is when you like someone
the first time you ever meet them?
I mean, really like them? Well, that's
how it was with me and Indiana."
Boulane only has one other credit to his
name: playing baby Jesus in 1995's Marie
de Nazareth. As he seems to have retired from
acting around the same time that he grew teeth,
it's perhaps no surprise that Boulane's
current whereabouts remain unknown.
Chris Strompolos' depiction of Indiana
Jones might not be in the official canon,
but his tribute movie, Raiders of the Lost Ark:
The Adaptation, has become a legendary feat of
film fandom. As a 10-year-old living in Gulfport,
Mississippi, Strompolos and his friend dedicated
much of their childhood to remaking Raiders of the
Lost Ark scene-for-scene, an undertaking that took
seven years to complete. As to why Strompolos made
the project, he later told the New York Times:
"I just wanted to be Indiana Jones.
I wanted to see what it would be like
to be so self-sufficient and
get in and out of trouble."
In the years after its 1989 completion, Raiders
of the Lost Ark: The Adaptation garnered a cult
following. These days, Strompolos has traded
in his Indy fedora and whip for a computer,
with his LinkedIn page suggesting
that he works in animation and VFX.
Welcome to the dregs: Tony Cox plays Indiana
Jones in 2008's Hollywood spoof Disaster Movie,
joining a long tradition of pop culture parodies
of the iconic hero. Indiana Jones parodies are
nothing new, of course, and Cox's portrayal of
the man in the hat isn't all that groundbreaking.
His raunchy take on the character suits the vibe
of Disaster Movie to a tee, but that's hardly a
compliment considering the movie currently sits
at a paltry 1% on Rotten Tomatoes' Tomatometer.
"Indiana my ass!"
Still, Cox's appearance in such an
atrocious movie doesn't mean he's
not a fine actor. With film
credits dating back to 1980,
Cox has scored parts in movies ranging
from Willow to Beetlejuice to Bad Santa.